- Hello, I'm Gav.
- I'm Dan.
We're the Slow Mo Guys,
and welcome to the loudest week
of "The Super Slow Show."
Looking forward to this!
- Dan's cup of tea.
- Love blowing stuff up.
Using explosives
or should I say exslowsives.
- There it is.
- Yeah.
We're gonna be blowing up
a sandcastle,
annihilating a house,
exploding some fruit.
Whoa!
That was a shock wave.
That was--
nailed it.
- That was quite good.
- Well done.
( music playing )
Welcome
to "The Super Slow Show."
And you've joined us
in our ongoing war
against fruit.
Yeah, particular favorite
watermelon,
but I do like blowing
fruit up for sure.
It just fragments
so nicely.
Like the one we did
on the table.
- Yeah.
- That hit you in the face.
Not gonna stand next to it
this time.
Today we've got it
on the spin rig.
We'll get the camera moving
rapidly around it,
a thousand frames a second.
And then maybe we'll throw
some more fruit in.
Dan: Upscale it,
see what that looks like.
Upscale the fruit,
upscale the bang.
Let's get to safety.
Quick.
- Okay, here we go.
- Good-bye, melon.
Three, two, one, bang!
- Oh, that's good!
- Whoa!
- Yeah, look at that.
- There!
And it finally landed.
That was ages.
I like it even though
I've seen the melon blow up
countless times.
I'm always excited
to watch it.
Always have to go
and find a piece to eat as well.
I don't think
there's much left of that one.
- Yeah.
- We sort of misted the inside.
- Got eviscerated.
- Now we go and watch it.
Yeah.
Gav:
Such an innocent melon.
It just doesn't know
what's about to happen to it.
Dan:
It was in the shop thinking,
probably gonna be chewed up
and eaten and all that.
Maybe like a family of, you
know, nice husband and wife,
- three kids.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
- They'll tuck into the--
- Wait a second.
( both laugh )
Dan:
Hold on.
Gav:
Something's not right.
Whoa!
- Geez.
- Yeah.
Dan: Flip.
That was an execution.
Gav:
There's loads of pits.
Dan:
It just-- I feel like
that can't be that small
amount of watermelon.
As in it just completely
misted it.
- It just disappeared.
- Gav: Yeah, there's not very
big chunks.
- Dan: No.
- Gav: Look, just sailing
through the wind.
Cool particles, though.
I feel like that amount
of explosives could blow
a hole in a lot of fruit.
What do you think next, 'nanas?
- For sure. Yeah.
- Bananas?
- Dan: Really don't like
bananas.
- Gav: I love 'em.
I'm hoping
there's enough of a chunk
- that I can eat some.
- I'm gonna blow 'em up.
So here you go.
All right, ready?
- Yeah.
- Three, two, one.
Dan:
Just turns to smoothie quick.
Instant banana split.
Gav:
I feel like if I was riding
the spin rig right now
I'd have a cup or something.
Dan:
Is it gonna hit?
Oh, there some banana
hit the screen there.
Yeah, look at that.
Oh, that does look
rather unappealing.
- Yeah.
- Unappealing.
Dan:
Thank you very much.
How much to eat this?
I bet this little bit here
is sort of edible.
It has a bit sand in it.
( laughs )
Oh, man!
- Well?
- It's fine.
- Just tastes like a 'nana.
- Oh yeah?
- Yeah.
- How 'bout this piece?
- Might give that one a miss.
- Yeah?
All right, let's have a look
at the rest of it, shall we?
So what I've noticed
is that
it's landed pretty
evenly everywhere.
I'm thinking we load it up
with all the fruit we can get
and then you and I
both take a bowl,
place them
strategically,
and whoever catches
the most fruit wins.
- Think that's a good idea.
Yeah.
- Yeah?
So we just need an absolute
pyramid of fruit here.
- Yeah.
All the fruit we can get.
- All right.
For sure.
Is it weird that this is one
of the bowls
it just reminds me
of one of the ones
you used to puke in
as a kid when you're ill.
- I never puked in one of these.
- No?
- No. Weirdo.
- I did.
- All right.
- All right, time
for the final piece of fruit.
- This apple is massive,
by the way.
- It's huge.
Yeah, it's like a genetically
modified apple.
- Careful.
- Perfect.
- Quite a place.
- I'm feeling good about...
right here.
- Yeah, I'll go here.
- All right.
- Here's good.
- Interesting choice.
Do you think any fruit
will be left on there?
No.
I can't--
Do you think this is
the most exciting
fruit salad ever?
It looks so delicious.
Can't wait to blow it up.
Ready?
Three, two, one, boom!
Both:
Oh!
Yes!
I'm not being funny,
I saw some of that disappear
- into the distance
like in the mountains.
- Man!
Maybe someone hiking down there
just like... boop.
Just walking along,
just like...
Yeah, thanks for that.
Oh, that smell.
Can you smell that?
( sniffs )
( laughs )
I'm not gonna look
in my bowl yet.
You go stand by yours.
- Okay.
- All right.
( laughs )
How much you got?
I just got some seeds.
( both laugh )
- I think I might have one.
- Laughable.
I think I might have one.
- Brown smear.
- I've got at least
a small piece
of banana.
Check it out.
There's actually
a tiny piece there.
Oh, he wins!
He's got like a piece
of apple or something.
Look at that.
You've got some sort
of like slime.
- Wouldn't eat either
of them to be honest.
- Uh, not-- no.
Gav:
Just an innocent pile
of fruit standing--
- Oh, wow!
- Goodness gracious!
Dan:
Look at the top of that
pineapple just go.
- That is amazing.
- All of the stuff on the inside
just got turned to dust,
just mush
and then a whole pineapple
flying though.
- Come to the lens.
- Oh!
Caked the lens with fruit.
I wonder what the top
down looked like.
'Cause-- oh, yeah
that's wicked.
- Yeah, let's have a look
at the top down.
- Yeah.
- Oh.
- Whoa!
- So it went outwards.
- Yeah.
Gav: It wasn't actually
an upward blow.
Dan: Although this one's
coming straight up.
- Is that a rogue mango?
- I think it's a rogue mango.
( sighs )
We just did the experiment
again off camera
and this is all the fruit
we caught this time.
Look, there's fruit
that wasn't even in the pile.
Yeah.
- We're very convincing.
- Yeah.
Well, I thought those shots
looked amazing.
It's always nice to send pieces
of fruit to the moon.
If you happen
to live on the moon,
you can just keep it.
We don't want it back.
Thank you very much
for watching that video
and we will see you next time
on "The Super Slow Show."
All I just did there was eat
fruit while you did the outro.
- A bit one-sided, that was.
- Yeah.
( music playing )
Hello, again!
We're gonna break stuff.
- A lot of stuff.
- Maybe even a limb or two.
Why did it have
to be my limb?
Unfortunate.
It's unfortunate.
Click here to subscribe
to The Slow Mo Guys
if you haven't already.
I have.
- Have you?
- No.